each year the Alps around kitzbühel
hosts a very special event and these are
the star attractions 194 classic and
vintage cars open top racecars elegant
coupe a's roadsters and sedans dating
from the pre-war period to the modern
era the final preparations are being
made then the starting pistol is fired
and the 26 kitzbühel alpine rally is
underway around 400 kilometers lie ahead
of these drivers the rally is conducted
over the course of three days Kirby the
famous Love Bug is also taking part
the convoy travels through picture
escapes making kitzbühel a car lovers
dream any vehicle that boasts four
wheels in a unique history is welcome to
join the colorful parade whether small
like this Isetta from 1956 or really big
like this state car from 1963
this man says his wife was reading a
newspaper and said I don't believe it
look isn't that a check so he looked and
told her it was an old parade car a
Changkat convertible
he said he must have it so he called up
the auction house did over the phone and
got the car he tells us that it's a
government car that was only used for
parades now it's 50 years old and it's
just 50,000 kilometers on it which is
nothing for a vehicle like this and
Lemmy says he and his general decided to
dress in the Soviet Army uniforms of
that era okay it's good that the general
has an extra handlebar to hold on to
rally drivers must also pass various
tests along the route some are about
driving skills others involved time test
sections is it nerve-wracking a little
she admits but now they're used to it
then they leave the men eating their
dust that's her main goal Kirsten says
men radically underestimate us that we
show them the participants include real
professionals like German Touring Car
driver Mike Rockenfeller he puts his
1984 outie sport Quattro through its
paces during the tricky test sections
Rockenfeller says the weather's great
and they enjoy the drive he hopes
they've done fairly well on the tests
I'm not sure now spot
Harley drivers need a good copilot who
ensures they stay on the right route and
keeps an eye on the competition
he says she's vital in that he'd be lost
without her she agrees he says they've
had three arguments the fewest they've
ever had here so things are going well
but even the best of relationships
doesn't help if your vehicle refuses to
play along like this 1956 Porsche
speedster this driver says the
speedometer cable broke yesterday so
they drove all day without knowing their
speed or mileage and he says this
morning the battery cable fell off he
says it took them an hour to get the car
going which is why they're a bit late
but he says they enjoyed the weather and
the lack of stress because their times
are all messed up anyway the one car
just keeps going and going
Herbie with actors amatzia behind the
wheel
Jesus collective vomit says the feeling
of being part of a group is unique
people say that the kids build classic
is one of the nicest rallies around
because you travel through such
beautiful landscapes but he says as a
driver you're concentrating on the key
points and what's demanded of you so you
don't even notice the landscape it's
only thinking about where he has to go
and when turn left or keep going
straight this is copilot sure the actor
says you really have to concentrate to
arrive at the finish safe and on time
and that's what it's all about
Pelham gates on the rallies third and
final day the cars crossed the finish
line in Kitts boos historic old town
spectators line the streets and marvel
at the classy cars here our Hollywood
star herbie is in his element while the
russian parade car in its general do
what they do best
you